yeah that nerve game is pretty crazy not
nearly as crazy as Pokemon go has
actually become in the real world but
get up not bad for fiction so nerve
stars emma robertson dave franco emma
roberts is his girl she's a really good
a good a girl she never takes chances in
her life and of course she has that one
friend who takes all the chances in the
world who's actually insecure deep down
and in this world in this film there is
a game called nerve that people play on
their phones ultimately truth or dare -
the truth watchers dare players to do
certain things and they get a certain
dollar amount then they move up the
online ranks as games work and it gets
addicting and people go too far this how
is going to go so at a point emma
roberts friend tells her you never take
chances ever roberts like you know what
i'm gonna play nervous ones across dave
franco and now they're a nerve team yes
that's my nerve team wiggle pretty fun
time i got to say first of all emma
roberts i like emma roberts she's good
in what she does she's not bad to look
at very easy on the eyes i got a set
more importantly perfectly fills that
role of someone who just like she is
girl next door you know she has edge but
that's only if you push her far enough
to have it but ultimately for the most
part I was having fun watching the Dare
scenarios that were happening I was
really fascinated with this game cuz it
causes you to reflect you're like what
would I do what I played nerve I feel
like I would play nerve but you know
nerve would become way too sexual way
too quickly like that those first couple
ones might be normal and after that it
would just be gross have a bum lick your
balls who you're not gonna do it are you
gonna lose the game it never really goes
there in this movie which right they're
like oh that's just not realistic the
most unrealistic thing in this entire
scenario in this movie is the fact that
no one actually really got gross and
sexual on their dares two minutes it
would just completely go there but I
like this world of this messed up game
they created for this film I really
thought it was intriguing he can't help
but be intrigued in this movie as you're
watching it because you're like would we
go there as a society if it were legal
would I play the game and what would my
boundaries be and that's where this
movie is a lot of fun because this movie
keeps it in the pocket and knows what it
is the last act of this movie was a
little bit alright we'll call it
over-the-top it's like the movie just
stretched a little too far and tried to
be a little too epic this movie already
has you on the fringe because if this
game could have survived in our world it
would have happened in our world already
seriously the fact that it's not around
shows that it couldn't happen but
you suspend your disbelief because
you're having fun with it and then the
last act happens you're like a little
too far guy alright come on Bishop but
it does have a good message or at least
monologue in it where it's like yeah
it's really easy to say you have nerve
behind your little keyboards as you're
talking [ __ ] but really come out here
and do this no it's different a lesson
for a lot of commenters a down there in
the comments section not pointing it all
of you I'm just saying I've done this
for a while there are some [ __ ] bags in
the comment section but guys in the end
for the most part in this movie nerve
kept it in the pocket and I actually
enjoyed it it was a cool not truth or
dare but dare or lose game it's cool
seeing this girl come out of her shell
her and dave franco worked well together
you by the fact that all the nerf
players are like how about you to team
up because just a little more fun last
stack it's a little wonky and cartoony
but by the end even the last act the way
it wrapped up I enjoyed that makes any
sense point is I enjoyed nerve I will
say nerve is a good time no alcohol
required right guys so nerve have you
seen it what did you think about it
what's the craziest dare you've ever
accepted and done whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more